well let's get more now on the
government's anti-strike legislation
which will set minimum service levels
for fire ambulance and rail Services
when the sectors decide to take action
the bill will leave unions at risk of
being sued if they fail to comply or
join me now the conservative MP for
Newbury Laura Faris and and what is your
view about this potential anti-strike
legislation
well I don't think I would call it
anti-straight legislation because
minimum service levels in essential
services are common practice in all the
states that we would identify as similar
in Canada Australia the United States
um Italy Spain so this is just bringing
British legislation into line with our
European equivalence really
hmm
but the factor of the matter is that the
strike action that has been that has
happened so far does appear to make a
difference doesn't it we know that the
government is now going back to the real
uh operating companies and saying you
can offer more money uh they wouldn't
have done that would they not had the
strikes not happen so it kind of shows
that the strikes do make an impact
doesn't it
well I think in any liberal democracy
any functioning liberal democracy there
is a kind of healthy ebb and flow
between trade unions and governments and
that would be true in any of the
countries that I've just listed but
that's actually a separate point from
minimum service levels and they don't
apply in every sector so plenty of
sectors would still be able to to strike
in the usual way but it's simply the
sectors actually they were already
identified in the 2016 Trade union acts
there are six of them that are
identified as very important Public
Services they include things like fire
so that if the union wishes to go on on
strike the public can still feel
confident that a domestic fire will not
be allowed to rage unchecked there will
still be an engine that can come out
equally for category one ambulance
services there will still be an
ambulance on call and actually the right
to strike has never been an unqualified
right sometimes you listen to opposition
politicians and they make it sound as if
it's an unbridled right it's not article
11 of the European Convention of Human
Rights where it sits allows it to be
restricted as long those restrictions
are necessary and proportionate and the
international labor organization which
is a UN Agency of which the UK is a
founding member has approved minimum
service levels so so long as they're
confined to the most important services
in all of the countries are listed
before from Canada to Italy Australia to
France and so as I say it's bringing our
legislation in line with others it
shouldn't be conflated with what happens
in any individual strike and the way the
government of the day will respond but
it does give the public that confidence
that the most important services will
still offer a basic level of protection
irrespective of industrial action but
that already happens doesn't it we saw
with the ambulance strike that those
most severe category response were still
being responded to that's a very good
example actually so that's not quite
right we saw with the nurses strike that
there was a voluntary agreement to put
in a sort of national minimum level that
would meet the requirements that are set
out in this bill but with ambulances
what you saw was localized Arrangements
done on an ad-hoc basis sometimes the
local NHS trust didn't find out till the
morning what if anything was going to be
provided and when you looked at the
category one services so that is the
most critical call out services on the
day that the times varied wildly
depending on where you were in the
country now you have actually made a
really good that which is with the
greatest respect that that is the point
that the ambulance workers are are
striking about though isn't it they
would say that actually whether it was a
strike day or not that their response
times are varying massively because
they're absolutely struggling to to
offload their patients there is a
difference between category one where
actually ambulance response times have
remained very consistent close to the 10
minute maximum and Category 2 where we
have seen much wider variation anyway
it's a fair point to make but this is
about category one which is the most
critical so if for example there was a
massive Road accident on a Motorway the
call out time for that and and it is
fair that it shouldn't depend on where
you are in the country to know that if
you are for example in a huge Motorway
accident there will still be a critical
blue light service to come out and
actually one of the things that is worth
saying and is a Draconian step that the
British government wouldn't take and
haven't contemplated taking is that you
can ban strike so for example in the
United States 30 out 38 out of 52 states
banned public sector strikes altogether
President Biden signed legislation in
December that banned a National Railroad
Strike that would be the equivalent of
our Railways now we don't do that and
it's interesting actually even even
those bands all out bands have been
upheld by the international labor
organization as lawful so the government
could have gone further it hasn't gone
further it's protecting the right to
strike but it is saying that when the
service is one of essential public
importance then some minimum level must
be maintained on a national basis
are you confident that the government
has taken the right position on on
strikes because when we look at public
opinion you mentioned the nurses public
opinion in terms of support for nurses
striking has gone up in favor of the
nurses since they first started striking
and in some respect you might have
expected people to go the other way when
they became personally inconvenienced
you would have think that they would
they would perhaps have less sympathy
but it hasn't it's raised the the nurses
concerns in people's minds and more
members of the public now support the
nurses as a result of striking
well I think if you look across
different sectors you see different
levels of public support in fact the
story is totally different when you look
for example at education or transport
and I think actually the critical thing
is not looking at strikes through the
prism of whether or not an opinion poll
says the public or Pro or against and
nor should it be seen as a conflict
between the government and the Trade
union they are having negotiations I
mean I'm a back bench MP so I can't
pretend to know what's happening but I
know that the door is open and those
conversations although they're sort of
only beginning and progressing are
happening so I'm not here to sort of
create a defensive position
but I think that the issue with this
legislation is not about
um whether or not it does or doesn't
chime with public support it's about the
absolute basic protection which the
government thinks the public are
entitled to when the most critical
Services choose to go on strike and I
think that the challenge really for the
labor party is to explain why it is we
should lie behind every country
countries in the G7 countries we would
consider very very similar democracies
and economies to our own why the British
people should have a lower standard of
basic protection than all of our
neighbors
okay Laura Faris conservative MP for
Newbury thank you very much for joining
us